bonjour je suis très pressés parce que
j'ai invité joly françois un monsieur du
snob et lé facteur à déjeuner et il faut
que j'aille faire mes courses à casimir
normes une invitation
écoutez françois je vous invite tous à
les jeunes et super g en formidable j'ai
déjà acheté tout ce qu'il me faut mais
il ne me reste plus un centime pour
acheter le saucisson sec achète le pour
moi je te fixer rendez vous près de
pédalos tu me donneras discrètement mais
surtout n'en parle pas aux autres
casimir je suis là je t'attendais je
t'écoute joie bien qu est là mais par un
peu discrètement il faut pas que les
autres nous entendons allons un petit
peu à l'écart casting est ce que tu as
ça quand j'étais dans des briques asie
voilà le saucisson sec que dumas
commandes et j'ai pris le plus gros du
magasin remercie françois me sens très
bons donc qu'un vampire et table à mr
c'est juste tellement content que vous
inviter pour ça des jeunes et à les
importateurs à tout à l'heure
attention
voilà qu'a dit mieux je commençais ma
passion un peu de discrétion
excuse moi j'ai bien si ton invitation à
des mieux tant mieux
est-ce que tu as le poulets rôtis que je
t'ai demandé nous recommandons mais
enfin je lui sais pourquoi tu mets ton
monte où l'on déjeuné au relais enfin
qu'est ce qui se passe tout de même plus
si je te dis qu'il n'est pas populaire
au tc que j'ai bien vu regarde de co2
pour les rôtis ou j'ai pensé que le fait
que les toits avec nos appétits
ce sera apte et jusqu'à un poulet aux
juges
j'ai eu tort de vous faites quoi mais
les discrètement dans mon caddie voilà
et non par à personne c'est trop bon
alors à tout à l'heure je compte sur toi
12h30 un cas tout à l'heure vous déjà
bien je vois que l'on peut compter sur
vous c'est bien pour tout résumer
exactitude que le pardon
qu'est ce que vous avez dit je goûtais
des fromages que je t'ai apporter ça
alors vous vous êtes encore plus
gourmand mois à bombay kazemi en voilà
des fromages
vous savez vous allez être servis par ce
que je vous ai préparé un déjeuner
excellent je l'espère bien des mois que
les connais tous ces fromages qu'est ce
que c'est ça pour moi celui ci on va
demander aux enfants qu'est ce que c'est
celui ci les enfants un camembert c'est
bon ça c'est très bon
comment s'appelle dur en sort comme du
gruyère du mobilier ancien et puis on va
là encore un chien chèvre voilà ma
casimir voilà tout est propre
je t'ai je vous remercie pour cofacteur
et je vous attendent tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure un voix au revoir
ça commence à pierre fait des patients
et comment faites vous lorsque vous
pierre fruit d'un taxi gars bien l'agent
martelons large comme ça c'est à cela
qu'elle partait sous sol là et puis je
soupire c'est tout ah oui bon il n'y a
rien d'extraordinaire il ya pourquoi en
faire un événement ah bon quels risques
vous avez ma crème renversée
la voilà la caméra remercie on attend
son étude amer l'envers aurait coûté ça
n'a pas d'importance elle est déjà
renversé alors un peu plus un peu moins
bon à tout à l'heure
casey est tout simplement rouvert ce la
table est vraiment joliment mise de ça
m'a l'air bien d'eau et bien attaquant
mais cheikh sami attaquant savait pas
drop eu lieu à julie la cithare terre
merci voilà merci à tous nos jeux ça
nous allons nous régaler mais françois
casimir à toi pourquoi casimir du ne
veut pas manger non il ya quelque chose
qui me coupent l'appétit mais que veux
tu dire explique toi
mais bien dans leur part qui est ici le
saucisson est offert par françois les
poulets par julie les fromages par le
facteur est la crème renversée par
monsieur du snob au galop casimir toi tu
n'as rien de dit et comme tu as tu des
remords tu n'oses pas manger me casser
ne vaut pas la peur d'en perdre
l'appétit alertons sur kazim et en août
par vous êtes vraiment mal élevés et
casimir que veux tu que nous attendions
enfin don dans ce déjeuner je suis le
sol par n'avoir rien apporté enfin pour
sûr je suis donc votre invité oui c'est
indiscutable bien alors est-ce que vous
prouvez poli de vous servir avant votre
invité au casimir